[Applause]
hello nashville
we are at the listening room in
nashville we're here all week and boy is
it great to see you
after spending so many years in new york
city coming here is like taking a warm
sudsy bath after living in joy behar's
armpit
believe me if i could move here i'd
already be here
which means it's time for
gutfeld presents why new york is
horrible and stupid and we need to get
the hell out of here as soon as possible
please help seriously please help us
[Music]
apparently no matter what befalls the
big apple nyc remains the media capital
of the world it's weird it's like
declaring afghanistan the best place to
open a gay-friendly bed and breakfast
i've tried
sure in new york city you could be
pushed in front of a subway train by a
guy wearing nothing but a smile and a
hospital bracelet
but really the broadway shows are to die
for
nothing makes you forget about your
grandma getting mugged for her false
teeth then a matinee showing of hello
dolly
have you tried our new york famous
bagels try a local deli just follow the
police chalk outlines on the sidewalk
and be sure to step over the bodies to
get to it
the good news is every homicide comes
with a free pickle and a bag of chips
so i want to get out of new york but i
have to convince more than my wife you
know there's my mistress and her kids
three separate states
but also i have to convince fox how do i
do that without threatening to go public
with those pictures of steve ducey like
you've never seen him before
they're disgusting we can only show you
the upper half
we know that the bosses are watching
this show right now
that's because people haven't seen a hit
this big since the last video of hunter
bite and puffin on his crack pipe
thoughts and prayers so maybe i should
compare and contrast both cities
today we went all over nashville and
looked at what makes a good city real
estate civility cleanliness of the
massage parlors
they love they love their massage
parlors
so does brian kilmeade
i kid he thinks a happy ending is when
someone makes it to the end of one of
his books
so here goes the comparisons first let's
check out nashville's food
how great does this look i love the
barbecue here it's so good it has peta
asking for seconds
now let's show new york city
yeah
[Applause]
that is a rat
enjoying a slice of pizza
yeah when when we get a pizza with
everything on it we mean it
so how about fashion all over nashville
great great looks hats boots now it may
not be your cup of tea but who doesn't
want to see tyrus in chaps and a bolo
tie
[Applause]
you know we do we do love our cowboys
except for cat
she thinks high noon means her lunchtime
bong hits
okay so we've seen nashville here's new
nyc fashion
mama
don't let your babies grow up the
panicking
[Music]
one of your old boyfriends yeah yeah
so what about real estate here's a
typical house in nashville it's gorgeous
so much space for all your stuff well
here's one in manhattan welcome back i'm
deb dimuccio with manhattan real estate
so this listing right in the heart of
manhattan open concept super charming
right now it's a 1.5 million asking
price oh
tenant is still here hi
you want me to show you around that
would be fantastic
[Music]
there is no bathroom you don't need a
bathroom
so
you always hear about southern
hospitality well here's nashville
pretty good pretty good pretty good
all right stop it
here's nyc
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
still waiting for his pizza
i can't blame them for being mad they
thought they had tickets to see a comedy
show turns out it was for jimmy kimmel
you know if you watch closely he'll
start crying
so what about entertainment well here's
nashville you can walk into any bar and
you've got incredibly talented local
bands kicking some major ass meanwhile
here's nyc
[Music]
[Applause]
look it's it's it's good to see chris
cuomo is moonlighting
poor guy
anyway so i think we know who won this
contest here but the other problem with
new york city it's full of people who
never leave new york city and if they do
leave and there isn't two shrinks per
block they come apart faster than
biden's teeth on a cobb corn
they know everything about vegan sushi
but nothing about the world for example
did you believe that photo of border
patrol agents going around on horses
with riding crops whipping people
you didn't because you're normal
you're not
joy read
but in new york city where every person
is either homeless or one sexually
harassed by a cuomo or sometimes both
these people are as gullible and stupid
as the studio audience for the view
so apparently the media thought that
these were whips
i understand the only time new yorkers
see actual whips are at their s m
sessions with their dominatrix
that's where i met john rich
[Applause]
still owes me 40 bucks
it's worth every penny though right you
know it
but it's always like liberals to see
things that aren't there i wonder what
else they think are whips
whips
whips
whips
whips
whips
whips
whips
oranges
[Laughter]
so we have a hellish problem on the
border and the dope from delaware had
only one solution let's ban horses which
raises the question has this guy created
even one job he's even spiked
unemployment among horses
people people like to joke about how
stupid everyone else is down south or up
north or in flyover country but the
moment they step outside their liberal
bubble it's like watching tyrus wear
khakis
meanwhile because
no no hail no hold on hold on what i'm
almost done i can't work i'm almost done
you can come after me so the rest of
america brims with common sense it's the
kind that tells you no they're not
whipping them they're trying to control
the horse on unstable terrain
you don't have to be the lone ranger to
figure that out
so that's why we want to leave we'd be
happy here
but don't you people get a swelled head
we already have one of those
we call him jesse
don't clap for him
[Applause]
welcome tonight's guest
he's so southern his blood type is sweet
tea
hey aoc good luck taxing this rich
country music star host of the pursuit
she still haunts jim acosta's dreams and
nightmares former white house press
secretary co-host of outnumbered
she's like a 100 bill valuable but
covered in cocaine fox news contributor
and his 10 gallon hat actually holds 40
gallons
my massive side kick and the nwa world
television champion
[Applause]
you know john we were talking before you
live here um is that one reason not to
move here
uh every time i go to nashville you try
to get me to shoot guns
that's right i asked you you know you're
here all week if you have a couple hours
off we should go shoot guns because we
actually still have a second amendment
that's 11 mil in this town
so yeah
if you want to go you want to go shoot
some guns you want to go fish you want
to listen to some country music ride a
four-wheeler eat a bunch of barbecue
that's my wednesday why would anybody i
don't see how anybody yeah i don't see
how anybody still lives in new york and
doesn't move somewhere else just to your
point do you
you come to new york
is there there's got to be something
redeeming there i mean listen i used to
love going to new york i was actually at
ground zero yesterday playing a concert
for like thousand tunnels to towers
thousands of people down there
and listen there's a lot of great people
in new york the people in new york
there's all these great people but it
was a different vibe man i've never seen
that when i was driving down i've been
about a year the cops they look on edge
the air feels different down there i'm
like man i always love new york more
than la always because the people there
even
comparing anything to l.a i like
psoriasis more than ever that's true
but but it was just definitely a
different vibe man yeah it's it's
changed it's sad kaylee kaylee you might
be one of the few people on the planet
that just moved to new york i'm the only
crazy person
hey i still live in the freedom loving
state of florida but sadly i have to
spend a lot of days in what we call the
death trap my husband who used to play
for the new york mets he loves the mets
but the death trap of new york city he
cannot speak for it um new york met so
they need good that's baseball right
tyrus i'm still stuck on you talking
about me wearing khakis what's the
problem
i have you hold on have you ever worn
khakis has anyone ever seen you a little
pair of khaki
i have one i've been seen in a war
in a pair of khakis on this show um not
not recently no thank you okay go ahead
you're just running out of stuff to talk
about
i i choose to dress this way that's what
i'm saying it'd be like you can't don't
work with my skin tone
people would think i would didn't have
pants on they'd be like oh it's the same
tone why would you wear the same thing
it always has to be about race doesn't
it
you went there talking about wanting to
see him in khakis well it's cause i
couldn't i just can't you can't pull off
khakis why
i can't pull i could take i put my leg
one leg on my shoe i could pull off some
khakis put you know what next time you
show up here with some khakis i'll pull
them off how about that
it was all an elaborate plan for him to
say that do you remember the night you
called me drunk at geraldo's house and
you said john please come hit me up i
showed up you were wearing khakis
i did see him once in her house all
right
so kat
uh how you doing you know i i'm okay but
i i do have to leave new york right you
hear my voice
kaylee give it a few years you're gonna
sound just like me hey i i'm i am 32
years old i am rapidly aging in that
city it's destroying me it destroys all
of us i need to move maybe here let's
not please
yeah
all right come on
i will say if i could i came up from
florida for the first time in new york
for about why you still sound healthy
yeah but then within within an hour a
rat scurried across my feet there was a
domestic violence dispute in my hallway
and there was a man peeing on the side
of the road that's a normal
i dream for days like that
all right we got to move on enough new
york city bashing i still like new york
but see
as long as fox is still there see this
you have to understand this entire
monologue wasn't for anybody at home
this was this was just targeted at my
boss
and then they're gonna look at the
ratings to go maybe he's got a point yes
anyway i should shut up now i still have
a job hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else